freunde der sonne eigentlich befinden
wir uns ja gerade in unserer winterpause
denn wenn ihr das hier seht befinde ich
mich gerade in meinem flitterwochen auf
der anderen seite der weltkugel in
neuseeland
ich wollte euch eigentlich nur ganz kurz
frohe und entspannte feiertage wünschen
und einen guten rutsch ins neue jahr
außerdem möchte ich mich bei euch
bedanken dafür dass sie immer so coole
konstruktive witzige und sehr oft
unglaublich schlau und intelligente
kommentare schreibt und das muss man
erst mal sagen können über youtube
kommentare der aufmerksame zuschauer
weiß dass ich versuche mir die zeit zu
nehmen die kommentare auch zu lesen und
sie auch immer wieder zu beantworten
weil mir diese austausch eigentlich
ziemlich viel spaß macht deswegen dachte
ich vielleicht mache ich mal ein cueni
fing und nutze die winterpause um eure
kommentare um eure fragen zu sammeln
also erstmalig sind normalerweise
stellte mir vor allem wissenschaftliche
fragen das könnt ihr auch nach wie vor
machen erst meeting
ihr könnt aber gerne auch irgendetwas
anderes fragen zu mir privat oder was
philosophisches oder ratschläge für ihr
leben das auch immer euch einfällt alle
fragen sind erlaubt ob ich sie dann
beantworte das ist eine frage für sich
am 11 januar geht es weiter ich habe
noch eine folge science news für euch in
petto ihr könnt aber hier oben abstimmen
was ihr zuerst sehen wollt am 11 januar
science news oder das clueso oder sowie
ein die beiden sachen die ersten beiden
folgen im neuen jahr sein so viel zu
meiner weihnachtsansprache
ich wünsche euch was bleibt sicher wir
sehen uns 2018